Well, if we're to deal with this challenge of increasing growth in distributed
applications, we should consider what kinds of technologies we can use to
support them. One category are technologies that provide abstractions, okay?
In particular, the abstractions take the form of interfaces realized as
application programmer interfaces, or APIs, such as Ajax or
Enterprise JavaBeans. Standards, think HTTP or
new kinds of architectures such as REST architectures or
service oriented architectures. similarly, the development of new notations.
Over the last, maybe ten years we've seen the increasing penetration of
XML into applications. And similarly, there's been the development of tools and
that support the development of these kinds of systems such as WebSphere or
Hibernate. You may have heard of those. In the design space,
there's Oracle's Fusion and there are even code generators for,
for transforming or generating the XML such as XSLT.